[Music]
today we are going to have the lecture
in MDS so we're going to work through
many new and interesting ideas hopefully
you would you'll learn a lot from
today's lecture they are going to have a
lot of fun analyzing and solving puzzles
and problems okay
already familiar position to you
Lasker's idea so let me just go through
it really quickly that we can switch to
another idea like - - another game with
the same idea so we can call this
position like different like elevator
how does it work
so first of all we need to open the this
part for the for the point we are going
to promote c8 Chuck again we're not
going back to see it but we are going to
another side trying to promote the rook
tries to stop the pawn and then you
start using your roof given the Chuck's
from this side King moves up and you
move with the King up to again check and
your you move with the King to a7 not to
c8 and not to a8 so now you see do you
see the elevators the rook age forgiven
the check King moves to a for King
defends the point from b7 and prepares
to promote from c8 rumba to Chuck and
now King moves to a six again elevator
Luke returns back to C to rook a for
root H for Chuck King ace rip probably
most of you already know that the idea
from this from this moment God the main
idea that we are going to sacrifice on
edge to
elevator the same scheme then Chuck and
then rook takes H to destruction the
main piece that protect c8 Square so and
now we are going to another position
with the same idea
two great players played these games so
that was the rail game petroi son played
against Karpov so carpa was black and
look at the position so white bones are
going to promote the power of six the
final age five and the route controls
the Quan and c2 so do you think that
black will promote the pawn who thinks
that black will promote the pawn right
your hand right raise your hands
but now let's think about the next move
the King is under attack so we have to
figure out where are we moving the King
either way Steen like on the same line
on a well basically we do not have any
choice we have to stay on the a file but
the question is a 6 or a 8 if we move to
a 6 what happens so each six excuse me
aged six so if the King moves to h6
Jonathan
right what's your name excuse me Azeem
my name is Anna okay so a zoom is right
57 try to recall the last Chris idea if
I if I play here then you just move the
pawn and the King takes do we have the
reversed Lasker's idea like in the
previous position and we go with the
same with the same line again elevator
exactly the same that we have reviewed
in the previous position
so let us return back again so when king
moves to h6 we push the pawn to to f7
key if the King takes on h5 what happens
came to b7 right would you like to just
see it on the board right so if the King
takes charlatan your move
q g7
engage seven
Roxi 5
and again elevator right biplane King to
h7 black tries to postpone this elevator
so the next note is h6 and if the King
takes again elevator try to use this
idea because when you play the game and
use the already familiar idea then it's
really easy because you know to which
position you're going to approach which
position you want to get that is why
we'll learn all those ideas okay so in
the kink most 2h8
Jimmy
King
Chuck
Shawn
you mean back yeah
there will be four one
not easy I told you Luke and gains are
the most complicated I want all the end
games though you know the idea still
there are so many complications that you
can face
why does king move
if you move here I get a check back if
you move to see file then I promote
let's return back and think so let at
the positions that we got right so the
goal is to promote c8 to promote f8
point and not to allow our opponent to
promote to c1 Shawn
if I take
okay and now let's talk about the
previous position Jonathan do you
remember when we started previous
position I told that King it was
reversed so King 287 was brain and drawn
so here most likely it will be hard for
white to promote the pawn let's try
let's try to prove that King h7 works
raise your hands who know who wants to
tell them off
white not white
look to see six trickier if I move the
King I will be just checkmate it if I
move the rook you will take the pawn
right okay what if I move the rook here
Shawn go ahead with your with your
variation let's take care right and then
how are you going to defend from the
side Chuck's Chuck
impossible right because the king is too
close so once you are you're moving a
king too far then the King comes here
and the King blocks everything so the
king is cut from the sixth-ranked you
will never approach the pond so most
likely King H several works as we saw in
the example instead of H seven any other
ideas that you may have
let's see
oh excuse me rope the Systrom
if I returned back with a king to h7 so
let's start from the very beginning to
make sure that we on the right place so
the king was under attack we analyzed
the line King to h6
King h8 was played in the game here King
muffs here mineralized the King if the
King takes on h6 then what happens and
how how is it called
Jimmy the elevator or Lasker's idea
right so we were stuck at King h8 the
way so still why to play let's try and
give it a Chuck
so if a block with the rook I moved to
here Jeff one you cannot promote because
I take your take and I will promote so
you have to go back and to control the
pond I returned back with the check if
you move here I move back if you take on
c2 i take on f7 and it's draw so you
have to do something so well I cannot
find any winning continuation so maybe
this did also brings draw let us see how
Karpov played here he played key to h8
f7 so this is logical right that the
pawn tries to promote King to rook to e1
look at this move the rook doesn't move
to any other plate but exactly to a-1
King 2 is 7 King opens this part to the
pawn but trying to promote Chuck if the
King moves back then the rook most a1
can t c6 check back
and the king
finally the king is happy he is in a
safe place no checks and you see the
shreds right they see checkmate from
from f8 checkmate from c8 can't prove
the last or maybe we have some defense
Jonathan what defense do we have here
yeah
again logical but I take if you take
checkmate from f8 James excuse me tell
me your name please
Jensen sorry Jensen and I think gentle
they have any ideas here Azeem
of course but to play if it was wide to
play then just f/8 check and just loosen
if the rook takes on c1
first of all let's figure out what's
going on here look to g6 as in your
right and what are this Jimmy it's a
stalemate so that was the goal
so first opportunity that was like what
was why trying to use the elevator and
blacks goal was trying to get into the
stalemate I think that there was a kind
of complicated one right and we are
going to another topic so we are opening
the bishops end games look at these
bishops what can you tell me about them
Jonathan opposite colors bishops what
what do you guys know about opposite
colors bishops that's fairly often the
person this in games they end up in drum
but look at this position I'm going to
beat you with black I have two extra
points I am going to bring my king and
just to push the pawns your goal is to
make the draw so now you're going to use
your pieces of paper and write down how
you're going to make the draw with white
what are the merit of too big of
opposite colors bishops when you have
that your opponent Bishop cannot control
the same squares that you can control
you see so so fortress is controlling
the squares in from in front of the
opposite side pawns that your opponent
cannot control
you see you will understand it once you
see the end in position but I cannot
tell you the solution sorry this is the
puzzle you have to work on it
Jonathan tell us the first move
c5 can you believe we're going to give
up one more porn why are we going to
give up this pawn Shawn do you really
need this pawn when our opponent is
going to wean us on the kingside do
Varela need this pawn we have to use the
advantage that the opponent's king is
too far from the phone from from the
King side pawns of course Bishop takes
Bishop to b3 exactly we are going to
force the opponent to push the pawn from
a 6 to e5 and now do you see the
structure of the fortress what are we
going to place on what king and what are
we going to place on a bishop this is
really important with you can start with
a bishop but it doesn't really matter so
the king will be placed on e4 and the
bishop will be placed on g4 or on f5 any
other square on this diagonal isn't it
funny
right so now you know what it was
fortress means like from the first
glance black was winning but after
sacrifice in the pond you got to the
position where black can do nothing and
do not forget to place your kink on f4
because if you place a bishop on e4 then
you will have you will get it will give
slight chances to your opponent so in
this position you have everything
settled down and
it's good for you I'm ready to move to
more complicated positions opposite
colors bishops in two points what do you
know about these positions have you met
them before maybe you met them in your
in your own games No
so Azim what do you think about this
overall tell me about these type of
positions what do you think without
moving the pieces what did the plan what
did the plan so you play with white
pieces guys and of course your opponent
wants to sacrifice his bishop for your
two pawns and to get to the draw
position because everybody knows that
the bishop and the King cannot win
against the soul King right so this is
my goal I want to sacrifice my vision
for two points and will be happy with a
draw but I assume you do not want the
draw what is your plan how are you going
to beat me but if you place your your
pawns on the dark squares then I will
place my King and the bishop on the
light squares and just block them and
then it will be drawn be careful with
that because you want to make it secure
to place the pawns on the opposite
opposite colored squares right but this
is different you want to check me from
g5 this is what you want to do and then
to push your pawn to e6 to approach with
the King to e5 and then with the help of
the King and the bishop to move to move
forward let us imagine that we are
playing with black and we have to make
the trump what do you think how can we
do this now since you know that I am
going to check it from g5 if I whiten
your black and then to push a six why do
you have to do with the bishop think
about a six square Jonathan
so we need to protect is six so once why
it moves the point to e6 we just
sacrifice the bishop for both points
what we're going to do so this position
yes is good for both sides to learn it
how to try to win with white and how to
make the draw with black when you're
with you know playing for the weaker
side so you got it right Bishop g5 check
and then is six this is the winning plan
in order to make the draw we need to
protect ecigs we can protect essex from
which squares here shun from which
squares can we protect ethics
okay and Bishop to b3 right let us
calculate first Bishop to b3 okay I play
with white you play with black Bishop g5
check
excuse me bishop where you can you
cannot move to e6 I will just capture
the bishop with a pawn you're not giving
the bishop for two points here this is
your goal you want to tree into your
bishop for two points and then it will
be drawn way with black I'm you're
trying to defend so you first we chose
Bishop b3 we want to figure out when
we're going to do go ahead Jimmy Bishop
cheat right so if I move with the King
to the Queen side you just we keep your
Bishop on this diagonal and do not move
the King this is very important but I
have another idea
once you move your king to discover I
moved to f4 then I move to g4 and then I
moved to h5 so this is my idea play with
white a play with black Jonathan
Bishop Junaid I see a trick already I
see a tree because you want to play
Bishop seven when I approach now Bishop
a7 right
I'm up here
so King with an H porringer move you
have to move Bishop g8 and then I move
the King if you leave the bishop on this
diagonal and move to e8 then just is six
once I play is six and winning or you
are winning if you're white so return it
back to this position the Droid line is
Bishop most to d7 why is it drawn
Jonathan right because the point on a
five wil will be unprotected but you
have to keep the position in that way
that the pole will be protected and you
want we want to move with the King to
help the pawn from be five to be
promoted to e6 but once you place the
Bishop to d7 it's really hard to do that
only if black removes the Bishop from c8
h three diagonal now give you the Chuck
go ahead
Azeem
King to f7 again another rule that you
have to memorize you you have to keep
the king and the bishop both control in
which square who knows it six once you
move your king to f88 then what happens
is six and then I approach my king to
eat vibe and then will help my pawns to
promote I cannot play King to d4 right
if I play King to f4 your move Jimmy
Bishop c8 you need to control is six I'm
up here Shawn Bishop to seven so you see
it's really complicated to do something
memorize when the pawns are on the fifth
ring or when it's opposite when they are
on the fourth rank when you play with
black you can stop the the points by
place and both the king and the bishop
on the seventh rank but again another
important thing that you have to know
place the bishop is taking the pawn if
you play if you place the King and the
bishop vice versa then it will be a more
complicated to stop it do you remember
our previous position with a bishop from
beasts removing to f7 so Bishop b3 I
gave you the check the King moved to
December and I moved to a poor this is
the opposite position right
but still I won the temple
here is six goes if you move Bishop g8
then I am off key to h4 and I'm winning
the tempo and I'm approaching did it
once okay well this is clear with the
points on the on the fifth or on the
force it's easier to make the drum now
we are going to the next position
look at this position let's compare it
to the previous position what changed
John transfer yeah mm-hmm the point on
the sixth rank and that means that black
has less space am i right
so when the points were on the fifth
black had more space and one extra one
extra file we are to move the pieces but
here is it still possible to make the
draw a same one to think let try to
prove
okay Azim place with black Janet and
place with white I will move the pieces
so Adam Bishop d8 charlatan I think the
only move right King f8
you see it's really hard to make it up
but check
so Jonathan got the idea is right
because you do not have the ninth-ranked
right where to step with a bishop
so can get five I think
Jonathan
I think you should have started from the
other side because this side where you
place the bishop
belongs to which piece to the King not
to the bishop so in this position I
think as you found the way how would to
trick you and to make the drum of course
you can you can start over and change it
but you're losing the time so let's
return back to what we had here and to
this position so I didn't try to make
the draw and I think you found a good
idea once you made a mistake
what if you start with this mouth King
was here can get five and now guys what
happened what's happening Jimmy what's
happening with the e seven square
mm-hmm and this is the worst thing that
they can happen for black black has to
move with the bishop over the king we
know that with the King gets loose with
the bishop we do not have nine shrank
like we cannot extend the board that's
why we have to move the bishop away here
and then is seven and the Queen let us
try to do something from maybe bishops
is Reem Shawn you play with white now
thank you for the drum and yes made the
draw into a losing position do you
remember the Queen against the rook
did you make the last move
did you make the last move when I made
the draw no no somebody else but I would
I was so happy
okay
another attempt you came to a fire okay
okay how can I protect Bishop before I
have to go there Jimmy
it's I'm sorry I've lost
Wow way to play I'm playing for black
I'm trying to make a draw so you guys
trying to win me okay Jimmy you move
quickly everybody's waiting sorry I'm
just here Jonathan King just six and I
think you approached it to have seven
right and then eat seven okay so I'm not
moving to d8 I'm moving to f8 Adam
into
tamanna I think it's either right it is
a winning you just need to find the
route of the kink do you remember the
first time when we played with a bishop
- before I think and we were messed up
with it with Bishop e5 Jonathan do you
remember your variation when you gave
the check from b5 so here what are the
idea how we're going to move the king
it's understandable if we move to g6 are
we going to win if we move to g6 with
the king
no because the bishop stays where on the
diagonal h3 f8 right so this means that
we need to move the King where to the
other to the Queen side right how we're
going to do that if we move the king to
e5 who knows what happens the check and
then we have to move back to a5 to
pretend opponent of six but that pawn is
precious we cannot lose any point here
it will lose the pawn
we're losing what did the route of the
King shun
now king g6 Bishop III and we already
realized that so Adam came to to e4 and
what is the interest in I cannot attack
your corner of six why can't i attack
because ii 7 and e 8 promotion i have to
stay on this diagonal okay I cannot move
my King because of a 7 and I cannot move
my bishop from this diagonal so you move
Jimmy 85 I'm of back I have no choice
Jonathan Nexus 6 oh I am so happy I can
move the King will it help me Shawn
came to c7 returned back and I think
it's easy new guys already at the goal
okay who's next who who wants to tell me
the move raise your hand as a king did
you give me this check
but King to seven I think we can play
King to seven right away and then I
don't see any any defense against be
seven point
so remember when the pasta on the sixth
ring we are doing what draw a winner
we're winning but again if you are
playing with with sites that lacks two
points you have to you have to try all
your possibilities to make the draw do
not resign okay
so though you know that this is losing
never resign try try to use some
possibilities and check your opponent
whether he he knows that that he is
winning
how often your opponent doesn't know
that he's winning he tries their own
route I came and we go into the next
position another rule that you're going
to learn what do you think about this
position Shawn
it's a draw winning and try to prove
still wait that's a good idea because we
are dealing with a corner and when the
king is in the corner stalemate can be
possible so how can we do that so in
this position I will let you play with
black I will try to beat you with white
okay so let's start Jimmy your first
move
yes you guys have black try to make it
wrong
okay
you should have faith
okay I play here I think
don't forget about the Czech Bishop e7
check so if I move here you return back
with a bishop right I go back you give
the check so I basically have to go back
but instead of moving the King I will
try to move what I'll try to move the
bishop if I move here what is your next
move charlatan you take on h6 so another
new idea stalemate idea works when the
bishop controls g8 squares are next to
the king then it works off to Bishop h6
is wrong I cannot move to this diagonal
so I stay on my on my own there is no
where I was your mocha can you take on
h6 no because you take once you take on
a shift into King takes and then King g8
Bishop g5 check and then promotion of
the pond g7 if you move somewhere else
with Bishop to d6 then promotion let's
return back to the original position
bishop picture
I see idea if I move the King you have
the chance to check me and to force my
King to return back then you move back
but we have to analyze this mode here
because you cannot take on h6 once you
Bishop is on b2 so I can move my bishop
to the main diagonal go ahead
charlatan your move
Bishop's Israel cam
if I move to g5 you give me the check
right so I move to g4 I need to make
this route so you already know that when
you move the kink to the opposite side
you have to eliminate the squares of the
opponents Bishop right because if you
play to g5 in this position you will be
under attack and you will have to return
back the same was where the position do
you remember the previous one f6 and
ecig spawns and will in v square so you
have to eliminate that the mode I moved
to g4 my idea is to count closer to the
pawns and you have to stay on this
diagonal you cannot move anywhere right
because I will play g7 and g8 Queen so
Shaun your next move you're black you're
all a black so I'm trying to to win
against you you're trying to make the
drop
so you have to stay with a bishop on
this diagonal just to hear him
stern but I cannot you let us play here
we're here if you attack g7 king h7 and
then pink to d7 or eise Evan white so
again you have to stay here the King
goes to f7 can you do anything
preventing g7 so what can we summarize
from this position with a point on H 2 H
6 and g6
is it drawn as him
no white is winning so you have to know
that with the black of course you have
to try to make the draw to place in the
bishop on this lawn diagonal because
once you placed the bishop on f8 I just
I didn't move the bishop controlling g8
didn't allow you to make the stalemate
and then you had to leave that square
right because again you do not have the
9th rank this is what black legs right
ok with this position we are done that's
good the next one now we have more
points on on there on the board and in
the previous position so what we are
going to do what we're going to do with
the weaker side we were going to
sacrifice the bishop for the two pawns
memorize will it help you here if you
sacrifice the bishop for the two pawns
no because we have fun on the Queen side
that means that we have to create what
try to recall the fortress try to recall
the first position here it's more
complicated that position was really
easy it comparable to this position we
need to bring the kink right if we allow
the opponent to move the pawns to the
sixth rank it will be lost completely
even on the piece that will be already
hundred to do something so first we
cement the pawns g4 h 5 and then we're
going to bring the King King h4 king of
7 g5 but still the bishop from g1
controls H file you move the King what
will be a plus that your king will be
more active than the opponent king on h4
g6 and your next both as in
why did we move to e6 what are we going
to do next Jonathan King at five of
course we can we couldn't move
straightly to a fire because we the
bishop is on g4 that controls black
squares that's why we have the drought
g7 Sean I told you nobody sweeping the
only move you have here and you're
thinking okay thank you very much if you
move the king then it will promote we
should be three of course you were
slipping
that's why I asked you so after Bishop
b3 if I move the pawn Jimmy okay it
doesn't want to move it let's calculate
in the mind h6
kingi six bishop Israel
engage seven king g5
what is it draw because your king in the
bishop controls which square be gentle
g8 and the bishop can always protect
which point Azzam b5 so two weaknesses
that we have in the position with black
g8 and B Phi can be can be protected so
and the King moves to the pawn which is
on b5 then the bishop protect the pawn
from seaport if the King moves to f8 to
promote jeep on then both the king and
the bishop protect the g8 square so even
in these positions when you have pawns
on opposite sides on both sides the draw
can be possible so that's why of course
Bishop and games I think they are not
that complicated that the rook end games
I think we can calculate more like in
our mind because rook end games they are
more complicated sure again the rule
with what we started we started with the
fortress but that was easy
and we tried to answer the question what
is fortress and the bishops and games
it's trying to fortress is controlling
the squares that your opponent can not
control
but by controlling these queries you
stop your opponent's points and your
opponent cannot help his pawns by his
pieces right okay so what we'll learn
from today's lecture we learnt about
fortress in the bishop and games we'll
learn how to make draw when the points
are on the thieves or on the first force
rank right Bishop and two points against
the bishop will learn what happens when
the points on the sixth rank when the
King is in the corner and when the King
is in the center and we learned a little
bit about the rook in games about the
elevator
alas dress
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]